A qué hora y con qué fuerza impactará la
Península de la Florida el huracán Ian
Gladys
bueno como podemos observar aquí en la
imagen de la satélite pues continúa
acercándose peligrosamente a la costa
suroeste de la Florida se espera que
toque tierra esta tarde quizás hacia el
final de la tarde en un área entre
Sarasota y Fort Myers vamos a tener
condiciones muy peligrosas en toda esta
zona y vamos a ver la imagen del
satélite Aquí también la trayectoria
como ven es una trayectoria sobre el
centro de la Florida donde se esperan
condiciones catastróficas durante el día
de hoy lo más importante asociado en
estos momentos con este huracán
categoría 4 que tiene vientos máximos de
155 millas por hora es decir unos 250
kilómetros por hora es la marejada
ciclónica se espera una marejada
ciclónica de 12 a 18 pies sobre el nivel
del suelo entre bonita Beach y también
english vamos a tener condiciones muy
severas en esta zona debido de la
mareada ciclón Gladys que otras zonas se
verán afectadas y debido estas
condiciones severas que previamente
usted nos Estaba reportando Cuál es la
recomendación que se le hace en este
momento a las personas que viven en el
estado de la Florida en estas zonas que
serán más afectadas
bueno las recomendaciones permanecer en
casa en un lugar seguro alejado de la
costa evidentemente la costa va a
recibir primeramente todos los impactos
de este huracán es un huracán
extremadamente peligroso categoría 4 así
que por el momento lo mejor es estar en
casa en un lugar seguro alejarse de los
ríos y sobre todo de la zona costera
después de Ian Podemos esperar otro
fenómenos naturales que puedan impactar
la región del Caribe también el sur de
la Florida en Estados Unidos otras
formaciones en la Cuenca atlántica
Gladys sí estamos todavía en temporada
ciclónica en septiembre es el mes más
activo de la temporada pero todavía nos
resta todo octubre y parte de noviembre
así que de aquí a que termine la
temporada ciclónica posiblemente veamos
más eso sistemas tropicales